John and I are asking the Nerdfighters to
help us create the Happy Dance Project.
Hank and I said to each other,
"You know would be more awesome than if *we* made a happy dance compilation video? If all of the Nerdfighters sent us
*their* happy dances, dancing in front of *their* awesome places in *their* towns and neighborhoods,
and then we made a happy dance compilation video using all Nerdfighter happy dances!"
[Debbie Kitto – Happy Dance]
♫ When you feel like you can't contain your awesome ♫
♫ The feeling's rising through your body ♫
♫ Feeling joyful, thankful, crazy ♫
♫ when you're feeling happy ♫
♫ Out on the town or home on your own ♫
♫ In a crowd of nerdfighters or if you're all alone ♫
♫ Any time of day when the feeling grabs ya ♫
♫ You've really got to... ♫
John's voice: Nerdfighter happy dances!
♫ Dance! ♫
♫ Happy Dance ♫
♫ Come on, happy dance! ♫
♫ Yeah! ♫
Hank: Crazy happy dances!
John: I mean these videos are so crazy and sexy and cool, they could be a TLC album.
♫ When you're feeling the joy, don't try to contain it ♫
♫ Just let yourself go, you SO won't regret it ♫
♫ If you move it like Hank or shake it like John ♫
♫ Everyone has a... ♫
♫ Dance! ♫
♫ Happy Dance ♫
♫ Oh, dance! ♫
♫ Come on and happy dance! ♫
John: The dance that you do when you're incredibly happy. You, my friend, are a Nerdfighter.
Both: Get to the pyramids!
♫ And dance! ♫
♫ Oh, happy dance ♫
♫ Huh, huh, dance! ♫
♫ Everybody happy dance! ♫
♫ Uhhhhhhhh ♫
♫ Yeah! ♫
♫ Oh, happy dance ♫
♫ Yeah, happy dance ♫
♫ Show me your happy dance ♫
♫ Come on, happy dance! ♫
[Distemper – Think Who Is Your Friend]
[Music lyrics in Russian]
[Song ends]
[Debbie Kitto - Thank You Green Brothers]
♫ Don't fear the future ♫
♫ What a great year it's been ♫
♫ The world's a better place because of the brothers Green ♫
♫ Don't need to worry about the Nerdfighters' fate ♫
♫ This strong community will stand ♫
♫ Because today we celebrate! ♫
♫ John and Hank, we thank you for all and forever ♫
♫ This global community salutes you ♫
♫ 'Cause when our nerdfighter awesome is joined together ♫
♫ The choir sings hallelujah ♫
♫ You brought us intelligent humor ♫
♫ You brought us blended meals ♫
♫ You brought us "In My Pants" ♫
♫ You brought us DFTBA ♫
♫ You brought us songs on Wednesday ♫
♫ You brought us stuff on heads ♫
♫ You brought us awesome, you brought us together! ♫
♫ John and Hank we thank you for all and forever ♫
♫ This global community salutes you ♫
♫ 'Cause when our nerdfighter awesome is joined together ♫
♫ The choir sings hallelujah ♫
♫ John and Hank we thank you for all and forever ♫
♫ This global community salutes you ♫
♫ 'Cause when our nerdfighter awesome is joined together ♫
♫ The choir sings hallelujah ♫